y en directo a vamos hasta nicaragua ya
la denominada persecución contra la
iglesia católica llegó este viernes a la
detención del obispo de matagalpa
rolando álvarez junto a otros siete
colaboradores retenidos ya desde el 4 de
agosto álvarez es un conocido criticó al
gobierno de daniel ortega y rosario
murillo las autoridades le acusan de
organizar grupos violentos e incitarlos
a realizar actos de odio contra la
población conectamos con nuestro
corresponsal en centroamérica andrés
suárez jaramillo para ampliar la
información andrés cuáles son los
argumentos del gobierno de ortega y de
murillo para arrestar a monseñor rolando
álvarez y por qué se captura porque su
captura ha generado tanta conmoción
internacional
rodrigo muy buenas noches en días
recientes daniel ortega ha calificado a
los obispos de nicaragua como
terroristas como golpistas que incitan
al odio pero en el caso puntual de
monseñor rolando álvarez la policía
nacional emitió un comunicado en el cual
relaciona a este obispo con actividades
desestabilizadoras y provocadoras y aquí
es importante hacer una inflexión para
decir que nicaragua es un país
centroamericano
significativamente católico y religioso
que tiene mucha influencia los obispos
los sacerdotes en la opinión de la
sociedad nicaragüense y aunque esa
separación de iglesia y estado que
ocurrió hace más de dos siglos con la
ilustración en la cual hubo ese divorcio
entre el trono y el altar un divorcio
legal y político no se ha dado del todo
en nicaragua dado que los sacerdotes y
en el caso de rolando álvarez pues
influyen mucho en los temas políticos y
sociales del país por ejemplo hablan de
temas de inmigración del tema de los
políticos de el tema de los exiliados
basta con revisar las redes sociales por
ejemplo de monseñor álvarez para darse
cuenta de esto en donde él por ejemplo
hace uso de una retórica reiterativa de
la eucaristía haciendo la distinción
entre el bien y el mal entre el infierno
el cielo entre el enemigo y el vencedor
dios y aunque el propiamente no habla de
ortega son sus seguidores quienes
relacionan todos estos comentarios del
obispo con lo que sucede en el país de
manera que se podría hablar de una falta
de libertad de expresión que enciende
las alarmas en diferentes sectores
internacionales y andrés este arresto de
monseñor rolando álvarez es un capítulo
más de lo que llaman la repercusión
persecución política contra la iglesia
católica en el país que otros episodios
se recuerdan similares y como se ha
pronunciado en la iglesia católica
internacional al respecto
solo por mencionar los de 2022 junto con
el arresto de monseñor álvarez otros
tres sacerdotes han sido arrestados se
prohibió la peregrinación de la virgen
de fátima se expulsó a 18 monjas
misioneras de nicaragua hacia costa rica
pertenecientes a la orden madre teresa
de calcuta también se expulsó al nuncio
apostólico valdemar estanislado que
viene siendo como el embajador del
vaticano en nicaragua y se ha criticado
fuertemente internacionalmente que sea
el papá francisco que no se halla
pronunciado al respecto